in 1977 the cosmologist stephen weinberg
published a book called the first three
minutes a modern view of the origin of
the universe
the name of weinberg's book comes from
the fact that the first few elements
beyond hydrogen mostly formed between
one and three minutes after the big bang
weinberg's book is of course missing the
many developments in early universe
cosmology that have happened since the
1970s but it still remains one of the
most popular and important descriptions
of the universe's first few minutes
those few minutes are the topic of this
lecture
this lecture and the next few after it
are going to present aspects of the big
bang model that were already well
understood by the late 1970s when
weinberg wrote his book
our understanding of even earlier events
like inflation came later and we'll get
to those later in the course as well in
this lecture we'll see how in the first
few minutes some particles combined into
new forms other particles were
annihilated and turned into energy and
even the forces between particles
changed as the universe expanded and
cooled
in the next lecture we'll continue that
story up through the formation of stars
and galaxies millions of years after the
big bang
as we go through all this you're going
to keep seeing two important trends
first
as the universe expanded its temperature
dropped
all of the major transitions i'm going
to discuss in the early universe took
place as a result of this falling
temperature
second the time scales between
transitions get longer as we move away
from the big bang that's because the
rate of expansion and thus the rate of
cooling has been slowing down throughout
the universe's history the universe a
millionth of a second after the big bang
was a very different place from the
universe one second after the big bang
or a minute later
in the universe today by contrast big
changes only take place over billions of
years
why does everything in the early
universe depend on temperature
high temperature means that particles
move and collide so fast that they don't
bond together or if they do they get
knocked apart again right away
so as we move backward into hotter and
hotter times we see the matter that
makes up the universe broken into
smaller and smaller parts
the universe just a small fraction of a
second after the big bang was so hot
that nothing stuck to anything else
which means the entire universe was made
of its most basic building blocks
those basic building blocks particles
that are not made up of anything smaller
are called elementary particles or
fundamental particles
for instance electrons are elementary
particles protons and neutrons are not
elementary particles they're made of
smaller objects called quarks
but quarks are elementary so at a
certain early hot moment the universe
had electrons and quarks but it did not
yet have protons and neutrons
our current theory of particle physics
is called the standard model of particle
physics or the standard model for short
the standard model includes about 20
fundamental particles
most of those particles are unstable
however so once you produce them they
decay meaning they turn into other kinds
of particles in a tiny fraction of a
second
for instance one of the fundamental
particles in the standard model is the
higgs boson which made headlines in 2012
when one was produced and detected for
the first time at the linear hadron
collider or lhc in switzerland
particle physicists produced a higgs
boson by smashing two protons together
really hard
but the higgs boson they produced only
lasted a billionth of a trillionth of a
second after which that expose on
decayed into a shower of other particles
in the early universe super high energy
collisions were happening constantly so
new higgs bosons were continually being
created and then decaying
i've been using the higgs boson as an
example but the same thing was occurring
with many types of particles for a
fraction of a second in the early
universe all of the elementary particles
in the standard model were continually
being produced and destroyed
in this lecture i'm going to start my
history of the universe at a hundred
billionth of a second after the big bang
when the universe was at a quadrillion
degrees that's a one with 15 zeros after
it or a million billion
the significance of that moment is that
at that temperature typical collisions
between particles were just a little
weaker than the strongest collisions we
can currently produce in particle
accelerators
so we can experimentally probe the kind
of events that were happening at that
time
the universe a 100 billionth of a second
after the big bang was a dense
collection of elementary particles too
hot to bond into larger units
now let's start playing the story
forward from that moment
in addition to being just about the
earliest time whose conditions we can
recreate in a lab
a hundred billionth of a second was also
the moment of a major transition in the
early universe
that transition called the electro weak
phase transition had to do with the
forces between particles
there are four forces that act between
particles gravity the electromagnetic
force the weak nuclear force and the
strong nuclear force the last two are
sometimes just called weak force and
strong force
in the early 19th century you wouldn't
have heard the phrase electromagnetic
force instead you would have heard about
electricity and you would have heard
about magnetism and that makes sense
because electricity and magnetism seem
like completely different phenomena
lightning and the current that flows
through wires are examples of
electricity not magnetism
the force that sticks photographs to
your refrigerator and makes compasses
point north is magnetism not electricity
but in 1861 james clark maxwell figured
out that electricity and magnetism are
two different manifestations of the same
force like two very different looking
sides of the same coin
so physicists started using the word
electromagnetism for this one phenomenon
that unifies to apparently different
forces
many physicists believe that ultimately
all forces are different manifestations
of one universal force and they look for
models that will unify the known forces
after maxwell's work in the 1860s the
next big step in understanding the
unification of forces was taken in the
1960s and 70s when the work of many
physicists came together into the
discovery that the electromagnetic and
weak forces are two different aspects of
the same force which we call the electro
weak force
and that brings me back to the major
transition that occurred 100 billionth
of a second after the big bang
before that point you could not classify
one interaction as being due to the
electromagnetic force and a different
interaction as being due to the weak
force those two forces acted identically
as a single electro weak force
but after that moment when the
temperature dropped below a quadrillion
degrees that one force started acting
like two separate forces that behave in
different ways
one of those is the electromagnetic
force and the other is the weak force
and that's still the behavior we see
today
that change from one force to two
apparently different ones is what we
call the electro weak phase transition
theoretically we believe that at even
higher temperatures the electroweak and
strong forces would also unify into a
single force but the temperatures
required for that transition to occur
are much higher than we can produce in a
lab so we can't currently test such
theories experimentally many physicists
believe that at plank density gravity
was unified with the other forces as
well and there was only a single force
acting in the universe but even if
that's true we don't have a theory that
can describe what that force was like
so at 100 billionth of a second the
universe underwent the electroweak phase
transition splitting the electroweak
force into two
the next major transition occurred after
a hundred thousandth of a second
while that may seem like a very short
time to us it's a million times longer
than the time before the electro weak
phase transition in fact a hundred
thousandth of a second is a very long
time compared to most particle physics
processes
by that time the universe was too cold
to produce most unstable particles like
higgs bosons and almost all of the
unstable particles had decayed
what remained then were the few
particles that are stable meaning that
when left alone they last indefinitely
without decaying into anything else
when the universe reached a hundred
thousandth of a second it primarily
consisted of the same particles and
other forms of energy it does today
quarks electrons neutrinos
electromagnetic radiation dark matter
and dark energy
the one other big ingredient at this
time was antimatter which i'll come back
to in a moment
the biggest difference between the
particles then and now is that today all
of the quarks are bound up in protons
and neutrons
but at this early time they were all
flying about freely
to explain why that changed i need to
tell you something about the forces
between quarks
quarks interact with each other via the
strong force which binds them tightly
together into heavier particles such as
protons and neutrons
there are many other heavy particles
made of quarks but protons and neutrons
are the only stable ones
we never see quarks on their own because
the strong force that binds them into
heavier particles is so well
strong
within a proton or neutron the quarks
each exert roughly 10
tons of force on each other
that means it is extremely hard to pull
quarks away from each other
quarks come in three different charges
by analogy with the primary colors of
light which can be combined to make all
possible colors we call the quark
charges red green and blue
the strong force makes different colors
attract and light colors repel
of course parts don't really have color
in the usual sense color is just a term
we use to describe which quarks attract
or repel each other
a proton or neutron is made of three
quarks one of each color
so each proton is held together by the
strong force that binds its quarks to
each other
but if you look at two different protons
the attractive force of the different
colors cancels the repulsive force of
the light colors so the strong force
between two protons mostly cancels out
when the universe was above a trillion
degrees the quarks were all moving with
too much energy to stick together
imagine taking two small rocks and
putting sticky tape all over them if you
press them against each other and put
them down they'll stick
but if you throw a third tape covered
rock at them with all your might not
only will it not stick to them it will
knock the first two apart
for the first hundred thousandth of a
second quarks were constantly colliding
so forcefully that they bounced off each
other despite the tons of force pulling
the differently colored ones together
even if two quarks that happen to have
less energy than average were able to
stick to each other another quark would
immediately hit them so hard that they
would be knocked apart again
in the very rapidly expanding early
universe though the density and
temperature dropped quickly
that means that over time the quarks
were moving on average more and more
slowly
at a hundred thousandth of a second when
the temperature dropped below a trillion
degrees the quarks were no longer moving
fast enough to resist the forces pulling
them together
each quark almost instantly found quarks
of the two other colors combining into
color-balanced triads of red green blue
those triads were protons and neutrons
which is the form most quarks in the
universe have been in ever since
quarks combining into protons and
neutrons was the universe's first
example of a process that i talked about
in the first lecture
as the universe cooled particles
combined into ever-larger structures
but after the formation of protons and
neutrons the next big change wasn't
about particles combining but instead
about particles being destroyed
as i mentioned in the first lecture most
particles have corresponding
antiparticles with the same mass but
opposite charge
for example electrons have negative
charge and their antiparticles called
positrons have positive charge
collectively these anti-particles are
called antimatter
we don't see naturally occurring
antimatter around us that's because when
a particle collides with its own
antiparticle the two can annihilate and
release their energy usually in the form
of electromagnetic radiation
in the reverse process if you
concentrate high energy radiation in a
small enough region the energy of that
radiation can create a particle
antiparticle pair such as an electron
and positron or a quark and antiquark
we produce antimatter all the time in
laboratories and even in hospitals
a pet scan which stands for positron
emission tomography uses antimatter to
scan for activity in different regions
of the brain
but once we produce antimatter it only
stays around for a fraction of a second
before finding its matter counterpart
and annihilating
when the universe was initially filled
with a dense collection of elementary
particles those particles included
almost identical amounts of matter and
antimatter at the same time the quarks
combined into protons and neutrons
antiquarks combined into antiprotons and
anti-neutrons
so after a hundred thousandth of a
second the universe contained protons
antiprotons neutrons anti-neutrons
electrons and positrons
of course the matter and antimatter were
constantly annihilating creating high
energy radiation
but at the same time that intense
radiation was constantly creating new
matter and antimatter
we say that the annihilation and
creation processes were in equilibrium
meaning the rate at which matter and
antimatter was destroyed was equal to
the rate at which it was created so the
amounts of matter and antimatter
remained constant
but everything in the early universe was
subject to the effects of expansion and
cooling
as the temperature decreased the
radiation became less intense
and creation of matter antimatter
particle pairs became less likely the
equilibrium was broken and annihilations
began to outpace creation events
this happened first with the protons and
neutrons because they're heavier and
thus harder to produce than electrons
and positrons
after roughly a tenth of a second all of
the anti-protons and anti-neutrons were
gone
the positrons and electrons remained in
equilibrium with equal rates of creation
and destruction for most of the first
second
by one second however annihilation had
begun to overtake creation even for the
positrons and electrons and by three to
ten seconds later the positrons were
gone
from that moment on the observable
universe has had matter but essentially
no antimatter
after all the annihilation was done why
was there still matter
because before the annihilation i'm
describing the early universe had
slightly more matter than antimatter for
every billion antiquarks and positrons
there were a billion and one quarks and
electrons
by a few seconds after the big bang all
the antiquarks and positrons were gone
and their energy had been converted to
radiation
most of the original matter was gone too
annihilated in the collisions that
eliminated all the antimatter
but there were still those one in a
billion particles of matter left over
with nothing to annihilate
all the matter in the universe today the
stars galaxies planets and so on is made
of the one part in a billion of matter
particles left over after the antimatter
was gone
we don't know why the early universe had
a bit more matter than antimatter but
it's a very good thing for us that it
did
so by this point in our story the
antimatter was gone and a little matter
remained but there was also something
else in the universe electromagnetic
radiation which includes light x-rays
radio waves and a variety of other forms
after matter and antimatter annihilated
there was a lot of this radiation
because that's where all the energy from
those annihilations went
in the 10 second old universe radiation
had more than a billion times as much
energy as the matter
in fact the reason we know the ratio of
matter to antimatter prior to
annihilation is that we can observe the
radiation that got produced
we think of light and other forms of
electromagnetic radiation as continuous
but when you measure it with very
sensitive instruments you find that a
beam of light is made of discrete
particles of energy that we call photons
when a matter and antimatter particle
annihilate they produce two photons
in the universe today there are over two
billion photons for every electron
that tells us that for each electron in
the universe today we originally had a
billion and one electrons and a billion
positrons and when they annihilated we
were left with one electron and two
billion photons
but let's return to the matter in the
early universe
in particular i want to talk now about
neutrinos those particles that fill the
universe today but pass through solid
matter with almost no interactions
to give you a sense of how elusive these
particles are if a beam of neutrinos hit
a block of lead a light year thick
that's about 6 trillion miles
roughly half of the neutrinos would pass
through unaffected
but for the first second after the big
bang the universe was so dense that even
neutrinos couldn't pass through
neutrinos constantly collided with other
particles
starting about one second after the big
bang though the matter wasn't dense
enough to stop neutrinos anymore the
neutrinos from that early time have been
moving freely through the universe ever
since
we say that at one second the neutrinos
froze out that term doesn't mean that
their temperature changed at that moment
it means they almost entirely stopped
interacting with other matter
another term you'll hear is that the
neutrinos decoupled one second after the
big bang
since that moment those neutrinos have
been flying freely through the universe
although they haven't been interacting
with matter the neutrinos have slowed
down as a result of the expansion of the
universe
those neutrinos left over from the first
second of the universe still fill all of
space today
calculations showed that these
primordial neutrinos should be coming to
us equally from all directions at a
temperature of about two degrees above
absolute zero
in 2015 for the first time scientists
detected this cosmic neutrino background
and measured its temperature at 1.96
degrees above absolute zero beautifully
confirming our understanding of what was
happening in the first second of the
universe
the next important events had to do with
protons and neutrons
protons and neutrons can transform into
each other in a process called beta
decay
when quarks first combined they produced
equal numbers of protons and neutrons
and for a while they each transformed
into each other at equal rates
but as the temperature dropped it became
more likely for the slightly heavier
neutrons to decay into the slightly
lighter protons than the other way
around
by about one second the decay of protons
into neutrons had stopped but the other
way around neutrons turning into protons
was still happening
so the ratio of protons to neutrons was
steadily growing
if nothing had happened to preserve the
neutrons they would all have been gone
10 to 20 minutes later
but another important event did
intervene
about a minute after the big bang
protons and neutrons began combining
into light nuclei in the process we call
big bang nucleosynthesis or just
nucleosynthesis for short
the key to nucleosynthesis is that
protons and neutrons all attract each
other via the strong force
i said that when quarks combine into
groups of red green blue like protons or
neutrons the strong forces between two
of those groups mostly cancel out
but suppose two neutrons get very close
to each other
some of the quarks in each proton are
closer to the other proton than other
ones so the forces between the quarks
don't perfectly cancel
the result is that there's still a
residual strong force between the two
the same logic holds for two neutrons or
for a neutron and a proton
all of those particles attract each
other with a strong force that is much
weaker than the force between individual
quarks because those quark unquark
forces mostly but don't perfectly cancel
out
but that residual strong force between
protons and neutrons is still strong
enough to hold nuclei together
but as we saw with individual quarks the
attraction between protons and neutrons
can't hold them together if they're
moving with too much energy
for protons and neutrons to stick
together the temperature had to drop
below about a billion degrees which
happened about a minute after the big
bang
once the temperature was low enough one
proton and one neutron could combine to
form a nucleus called hydrogen two also
called deuterium
two deuterium nuclei could then combine
into helium four two protons plus two
neutrons
and for the most part that was the end
of nucleosynthesis
you can imagine combining helium four
with a single proton or neutron or a
deuterium or another helium four but
none of those happens to produce a
stable nucleus so for the most part
helium-4 is the end of the chain
if nucleosynthesis had started out with
equal numbers of protons and neutrons
for example if it had started at a tenth
of a second instead of at one minute
then essentially all the nuclei would
have ended up as helium-4
conversely if there had been no neutrons
say if nucleosynthesis couldn't start
until 20 minutes then no nucleosynthesis
would have happened at all and all
nuclei would have ended up as hydrogen
but when nucleosynthesis started at one
minute there were about seven protons
for each neutron
so each set of 14 protons and two
neutrons produced one helium nucleus and
left 12 bare protons which are hydrogen
nuclei
after nucleosynthesis helium thus made
up about 8
of the nuclei in the universe
because helium nuclei are heavier than
hydrogen nuclei that meant helium made
up about 25 percent of the nuclei by
mass
i've discussed the fact that
nucleosynthesis didn't start before the
one minute mark because the universe was
too hot for nuclear fusion
nucleosynthesis stopped a few minutes
later because the universe became too
cold
at that point there was still some
deuterium left that had not fused into
heavier nuclei and since nucleosynthesis
was no longer possible that deuterium
just stayed deuterium
but after nuclear synthesis deuterium
accounted for only about one in a
billion nuclei
nonetheless measurement of that trace
deuterium in exactly the amounts
predicted by the big bang model has been
one of the great experimental
confirmations of the model
but why did nucleosynthesis stop when
the universe got too cold
the reason is that in order for two
deuterium nuclei to fuse they have to
first get very close to each other
when you put two protons near each other
they interact in two very different ways
they attract each other through the
strong force at the same time they repel
each other through the electric force
since they're both positively charged
so which force wins
the answer is it depends on how close
the two protons are if the protons are
very very close the strong force wins
they attract much more than they repel
and that's why a nucleus can stick
together
but the strong force is a short-range
force much beyond the diameter of an
atomic nucleus about a millionth of a
billionth of a meter the strong force
pretty much drops to zero and you're
left with two protons that repel each
other electrically
so now picture two deuterium nuclei each
made of one proton and one neutron
once again they will be attracted by the
strong force and repelled by the
electric force
if they get incredibly close within a
couple nuclear diameters the strong
force will take over and they'll fuse
but how can they get that close when at
larger distances they're pushing each
other away
the answer is that they have to be
moving so fast that they plow right
through the electric repulsion of their
protons
those kinds of speeds happen at very
high temperatures
so here's the bottom line there's a
relatively narrow range of temperatures
at which two deuterium nuclei can hit
each other so hard that they get close
enough to fuse
but not so hard that they then bounce
right off again the universe was in that
temperature range from about one minute
to about three minutes
after three minutes deuterium fusion
into helium slowed considerably and it
was all over by 10 to 20 minutes later
at that point the mix of nuclei in the
universe was fixed for millions of years
until fusion started up again in the
cores of the first stars
so to sum up the story so far at a
hundred billionth of a second old our
universe was a dense collection of
quarks electrons and many other
elementary particles with nearly equal
amounts of matter and antimatter all at
a quadrillion degrees
a second later the quarks it all
combined the unstable particles like
higgs bosons had all decayed and the
antimatter had annihilated with almost
all of the matter
a minute later protons and neutrons
combine to make nuclei almost entirely
hydrogen and helium a hydrogen nucleus
is a proton that hasn't combined with
anything else and a helium nucleus is
two protons and two neutrons
in the next lecture we'll take the
history of the universe up through the
formation of stars and galaxies but
before we get stars we'll first have to
make our nuclei and electrons into atoms